I asked Bayern once
um you know if the women that that are
on his show are an accurate
representation of the demographic in
Miami like I thought they actually like
picked
thotty like clacky hoes you know just to
sort of like amp up views and he's like
no that's that's they're everywhere yeah
like just just the attitude I don't know
if it's attitude it's just every chick
down here wants to like go toe-to-toe
with you they all wanna they all want to
like what's going on you and they want
to like talk [ __ ] back to you and try to
do like the boss girl [ __ ] like
um it's like it's just it's just so
annoying it's such a [ __ ] turn off
like
you know trying to have to just push
through that stuff
um just make sure not even more bother
but uh I had that I had that Revelation
earlier this week in our in our private
signal chat but the uh
um I won't say his name but um you know
one of our more uh religious guys posted
a proverb uh quote
um something along the lines of it's
better to live on the roof than to deal
with the quarrelsome wife in your house
and it's like I asked him when that was
um written any any you know uh suggested
it was somewhere between like like 936
BC and a thousand fifty you know BC or
something like that I'm like so for 3
000 years men have been dealing with
disagreeable boss [ __ ] is basically
what that what that piece of scripture
is telling us right like this is not a
new phenomenon well it's always
interesting because there's such a a
mixed demographic down in a place like
Miami we have so many people from so
many different countries especially the
women they're mostly you know got Latin
women or you've got uh the the kind of
crew that I'm running with this weekend
um are
like Russian women but so so I can
talk freely about the problem with
American women and women in the west and
they all agree with everything they're
like yeah like yep American women are
Patty [ __ ] um they don't want to fall
into a man's frame like you know the
guys that I'm um there's there's a
particular couple that is with this big
group that we're in now and she's got
him saved and her phone is like my king
and calls him like when I'm into problem
solve and he's always taking care of it
like it's a it's a very successful like
relationship Dynamic it's like very old
school
um and you just don't see that very
often so it's it's kind of interesting
to see that stuff play out
um
whereas you know normally it's and Janet
can speak to this too because I know
that's the demographic you know you
mostly obviously uh with where you live
and what you deal with it's just
completely different it's like it's like
a different [ __ ] planet I went out
with a couple a buddy from Colombia but
uh I was friends with him in Texas
because he was staying there for a bit
and uh so he's looking to he's married
has a kid now like solid dude like just
natural Alpha and has always known how
to like handle relationships but his dad
is his dad was like a Colombian Alpha so
you notice that with guys that have
strong male presence in the household
growing up they just intuitively know
how to manage their chicks and
um
so he went out and he's like oh I have I
have a couple buddies uh you might like
them coming from California like all
right cool so we all went out a handful
of uh American guys in this Colombian
guy and all night long there's a lot of
Americans down here because it's uh F1
races this weekend so even on the apps
it's all New York and Los Angeles I
thought I was in the wrong location or
had my VPN on or something like no
they're just all here for the the races
and then the The Day of the Dead events
and uh but going out this happened to me
a couple months ago too just over here
there's a ton of Americans out and it's
so crazy because I go out fairly often
here and you're kind of used to the
background noise in the environment and
the general Vibe of the place but when
it's full of Americans it's almost like
a reverse culture shock for me it kind
of slaps you in the head you just hear
loud mouth caddy unattracted white
chicks and then these guys are just
skinny and crossing their arms and just
just really weird and like the the guys
at the table with me they lived to some
girls like oh yeah dude all the all the
the girls we got to do that and you
could tell they were like Super Beta I
think they're talking about oh let's go
find a strip club or something I was
like no dude just like and I pull out my
guys I do it in Miami or when we meet up
too I pull out my app I'm like no dude
just set up your dating app correctly
and the girls just open you up they'll
match you and just drop your number and
they'll be like hey what are you doing
let's let's meet up at this place it's
super easy and I I didn't real time in
front of these guys then I dropped the
group a text yesterday
um it was between the eight and nine
o'clock hour which down here on Friday
or Saturday night because it's a flaky
culture that's where plans either fall
through or girls all of a sudden become
free and it's kind of like when you
watch an old uh movie and they they
depict Wall Street Traders they're all
trying to get their trades in and oh
here here here no me me that's how I see
it between the eight and nine o'clock
hours so I was kind of doing that in
real time in front of these guys like
guys here's how you do it and uh and
then I had multiple options come through
uh at the last minute I'm like oh no
here's a dilemma uh two two
nationalities that I both equally like
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out